pat do you ever wake up and miss playing
with nirvana or are those days so far
behind you
you know every once in a while me and
chris and
dave get together and we do play
as if we're nirvana and it's oh you do
really so i don't i don't have to miss
it we do it dave i didn't mean if we're
in the same town together
or you know whatever we'll get together
and job you mean you'll get where do you
get together in a rehearsal space well
last time we did it at the house where
we recorded the album
oh no kidding yeah we actually recorded
some stuff yeah
do you ever go back and listen to the
nirvana albums either you two guys do
you go back and say you know
i just want to go live that over again
no
no is it too painful yes yes
in other words emotionally it pains you
because when you hear it it brings back
every memory of recording or
touring or whatever it just makes me sad
it's hard sometimes yeah i mean there's
times where you're driving in the car
and like a song will come on
last night actually my daughter harper
she's 11. she's like dad can we just go
drive around she's been stuck in the
house for weeks she's like let me just
drive around i was like yeah sure
so we jump in the car in my van uh
this cool old ford van from the 60s and
we just drove around
like drove around the hollywood looked
at
it was like eight o'clock at night just
driving around and
come as you are came on the radio and
she started singing she's saying every
word wow i've never played her that
record
we don't like talk about nirvana and
stuff and she was singing every word to
the song
i was like that that to me that feels
good
do the kids ask you about nirvana do
they say dad what was that
she actually did for the first time last
night yeah
it was a trip she wanted to know if kurt
was
shy i think yeah i was like yeah he
kind of was she and then she said was he
shy
around people he didn't know or was he
also shy around people he did know
and i it was interesting it was really
the first time she started really asking
me questions about kurt
that was a first and uh it was great it
was okay and you know why that's such a
good question
because most of us don't understand
someone who is shy
but yet could go up in front of
thousands
that is exactly what she said that is
exactly what my daughter said last night
she goes it's so strange that he could
be so shy
but then stand up on stage and play
music in front of thousands of people
that's exactly what she said